cropica is in a bad situation caught
between death games and then beasts
assassins and the Phantom troop and
should he make it through all of that
then his reward will be to set foot on a
continent full of creatures that could
kill murder him in an instant oh yeah
well I really don't envy kropica right
now so what is his mission and is there
any hope of success whatsoever hello and
welcome to the new world review
sourcefird without mostly Hunter Hunter
my name is Liam and this video is about
our new protagonist of Hunter Hunter Mr
karapika no last name am I going to
explain his mission and his very
unfortunate and potentially inevitable
fate during the succession War this
video is part three of a recap series
designed to equip you with everything
you need to jump into Hunter Hunter when
it returns later this year with part 1
covering the Dark Continent voyage and
part 2 explaining the succession War
itself and so with all of that
groundwork laid we can finally move on
to karapika because yes we did need two
whole videos before we could even begin
talking about the main character
stepping back in time a bit though
karapika's role in this Arc comes after
a long long absence from the series as
the last time we saw him in any form of
prominence was during the York New City
Arc and his last appearance prior to
this was chapter 149 during the Greed
Island Arc garoppica was I suppose lucky
enough to be distracted during that
whole ant business but he did finally
reappear in chapter 339 at which point
we learned that he had been a rather
busy blonde managing to gather an
impressive quantity of scarlet eyes he
was able to do this because he
essentially took over the nostrad family
more or less becoming a sort of informal
mafia boss of his own and then using
those resources and manpower to track
down the eyes of his clan members and
while krapika says that with each I
attained he had to lose part of himself
to his credit since murdering uvogin and
poconoda karapika has yet to kill again
stating that there were two people who
told me they'd rather die than hand over
the eyes but they changed their minds
without dying which is still kind of
dark and look it's not so great but I
suppose the point is that krapika still
has yet to fully lose himself which is a
good thing then one day karapika was
visited by a man dressed in a cow
costume who we know as the zodiac means
ice storm who at this stage is basically
the second in command of the entire
Hunter Association but look if I was
karapika then I would also be
questioning the cow cosplayer what are
you doing in my Mafia Den Cowman and
after some brief hostilities mizai Stone
peaked karapika's interest by stating
that he knew where the last of the
Scarlet eyes were which happened to be
in the possession of sirignek huigoro
fourth Prince of the khakin Empire and
one of many many guests on the upcoming
Voyage to the Dark Continent for which
the hunter Association is providing
security for so the deal being offered
here is that in exchange for assisting
with security the association would turn
a blind eye which actually I guess is a
rather unintentional pun but they will
turn a blind eye to karapika's personal
eye-based business to which karapika
said yes I will do the thing although he
inherits quite a hefty role because
karapika was immediately recruited as a
zodiac and given the designation of rat
which was formally held by fellow blonde
mop pariston Hill who has since gone Mia
for unknown reasons to the association
and that that is a fascinating dark
story for a future video a karate it was
actually contacted for this position on
recommendation of leoria who according
to Chairman Cheadle is and I quote the
most respected hunter in the association
which side I will never get tired of
saying something very special to note
here though is that saraynik doesn't
just possess a large collection of
scarlet eyes he also happens to have
what appears to be a full Curt ahead and
not only that but a head that looks
suspiciously like krapika's childhood
best friend pyro karapika does not know
this yet but when he finds out look I I
think he's going to be a little bit
upset as well as very murderously
inclined but from this moment on
karapika officially becomes our series
protagonist and alongside helping out
the zodiacs with their various Hunter
related business he also sets about
implementing his own plan to get close
to the fourth Prince which is assisted
by the fact that six of the 14 karkin
princes posted personal ads on the
internet looking for bodyguards to hire
on the dark consonant Voyage
interestingly they didn't post these
directly on the hunter website they did
so on the quote official kakin Empire
website now very very important
importantly six is a number the karapika
is not he is unfortunately a mere one
person and so he formed a bit of a
clever ruse to make sure that each of
the six princes are infiltrated hoping
that one of them will be able to get him
close to saradnik and karapika comes up
with quite an interesting group of
people to work for him firstly he hires
Melody which is not so much as a
surprise as she is probably his most
trusted Ally at this point Melody is a
music Hunter whose abilities are musical
in nature and her entire life's purpose
revolves around finding a certain
composition known as the dark Sonata
secondly we have boss show another one
of karapika's York New City allies who
has the great Haiku ability allowing him
to create literally anything he writes
however the quality of said creation is
only as good as the Haiku written and
unfortunately Basho happens to be
terrible at writing poetry thirdly we
have izunavi who is actually the person
who taught karapakonet however by this
point karapika is more of a master than
a student so he pulled the very boss
maneuver of hiring his teacher to work
under him grappica also contacted the
Ninja hanza who hasn't had a prominent
role in the series since the hunter exam
Arc but most fascinatingly of all our
final member of this karapika crack team
is one biscuit Kruger which is
intriguing because krapika had never
actually met bisky prior to this point
she became a very key part of gone in
kilwa's life and it was actually kilwa
who recommended bisky and to be honest I
I don't know how karapika got so lucky
because bisky is one of the finest
hunters in all of the series thing but I
can imagine there's some vague promise
of shiny karkin Dark Continent treasures
at play here but that is team karapika
and not to be mistaken even though these
five people are all Hunters they
currently work for karapika and not the
association I mean they're natural
allies but their goals are distinctly
different and so each of these six team
members applied for bodyguard positions
with each of the six respected princes
all of which were anonymous because due
to various politics and then such like
that the princes were unable to disclose
their names however karapika chose to
apply for the profile that he thought
match 9th Prince hulkenberg because the
ninth Prince allegedly has a better
relationship with fourth Prince Sarai
Nick than the others however however
this was but another clever ruse the
second of oh so many ruses because when
karapika arrived at his job interview he
found himself standing before queen oito
and the baby known as 14th Prince Wobble
the reason for this is It's mildly
complicated basically Queen oito is
incredibly intelligent and wanted to
attract bodyguards who support
hulkenberg because he wants to reform
the monarchy and other hopeful
optimistic stuff like that so as a
result Queen oito sees the ninth Prince
as wobble's only chance of surviving the
war oh War that's an important thing
speaking of this is the first time that
krapika actually learns of the
succession War up until this point he'd
been under the assumption that this was
simply a Voyage to the Dark Continent
but at this stage he realizes that he is
caught up in a death game and thanks to
some frankly emotional blackmail from a
very happy baby karapika agrees to
protect Prince wobble and his team all
get matched with various lower princes
because none of the Elder Prince is
advertised for bodyguards because they
all have their own private armies and
mafias and other such things however one
big problem we would soon encounter is
acropica he was not the only one who did
not know about the succession war in
fact immediately after the black whale 1
departed for the Dark Continent the
upper level containing the princes was
thrown into Anarchy with the 14th
Prince's quarters immediately under
attack from a wide array of nenbeasts
some of these nenbeasts were the
guardian spirit beasts of the other
princes however also present were
assassins working for the princes and
the long story less long after a series
of deadly Mind Games lasting maybe an
hour at most but probably a lot less
nine of Prince wobble's 11 bodyguards
were either dead or arrested leaving
only two karapika and Bill this is Bill
by the way he is a good boy we like Bill
but this was immediate Anarchy some
people knew about the war and some
people didn't some people knew about Nan
While others didn't other people knew
about nen but not the war some people
knew about the war but not the then and
some people knew about the nen and the
war but not the specific nun of the
Guardian spirit beasts and basically it
all was and still continues to be one
big gigantic mess and in order to defuse
the situation or at least put a pause on
the Doomsday scenario krapika did what
crop does best which was to use his head
and after meeting with third princess
decided not only to reveal the existence
of Nan but also to offer to coach two
bodyguards from each Prince's faction
and now this is a bold maneuver because
in theory karapika is making his
opponent Stronger by Awakening God knows
what kind of weird abilities lie within
them remember there's a reason why we
have an entire Hunter exam designed to
decide who does and who does not get to
learn nen and it's to prevent that art
from being equipped by the wrong hands
however the greatest strategy a play
here is that krapika is trying to force
a stalemate and equalize the balance of
power the reasoning being that the
succession War actually has a time limit
it needs to be completed by the time
that the Blackwell one reaches its
destination so karapika's thinking is to
Simply stall as long as possible because
many of the older princes either know
nen or have subordinate to win then
users and in the case of the first Two
Princes it is both so krapika's nen
school was designed to give the lower
princes a Fighting Chance as well as to
gather representatives of each prince in
one handy location so that karapika
could could find out some information
about his Target sir ednick and each
Prince would send two representatives to
the school with two exceptions that
worked out nicely one was sixth Prince
Tyson who doesn't see the need for nen
training because she of course has her
own religion based on love changing the
world so learning Nan would simply be a
distraction to that goal and the other
prince who rejected the sofa was second
Prince Camilla who was already a
seasoned veteran and user and is in
command of her own private Nan wielding
forces however first prince Benjamin who
also has his own then using Army sent
two of his guards as well seeing it as a
potential opportunity for assassination
and Intel Gathering now in doing so
karapika has put himself in a very
unfortunate position as most of the
princes now have their focus locked
directly on him the ones who knew nen
now despise him for revealing it to the
others and the ones who did now see him
as a very important Pawn for victory to
be used in their War Games whatever the
case karapika is now receiving a lot of
what many people would describe as
unwanted attention however that unwanted
attention is exactly what karapika wants
because as precarious as his current
position is become coming a central
point allows him significantly greater
control of the events around him it's a
high risk High reward strategy and it's
far from the only one he's employing as
part of his strange protective duties
krapika was also forced to employ an
extended period of one of his abilities
known as Emperor time which he's been
using in conjunction with this rather
delightful ability known as stealth
dolphin to acquire other people's
inabilities and have Queen oito put them
to use while everyone else's attention
is on him the problem is after three
hours of continuous use karapika
suddenly collapsed and he woke up nine
hours later with Emperor time still
active now that's bad very bad even
because each second spent using Emperor
time comes at the cost of one hour of
krapika's future lifespan meaning that
this one mistake of overdoing the
ability cost karapik of five years of
his life in half a day but to be
perfectly Frank without using Emperor
time krapika does not have the tools he
needs to fight off all of the stuff from
13 princes so he's in a situation where
even if he isn't killed by a nen Beast
or a bodyguard or a prince krapika could
very well end up killing himself if he
isn't careful but he hardly has the
luxury of being able to pick and choose
when to employ his powers because we
have a much more immediate problem to
deal with could I pick as an end school
has been infiltrated by an unknown
assassin one who uses an ability called
silent majority which is a conjured or
emitted nenbeast that we don't yet fully
understand what we do know is that it's
not one of the Guardian spirit beasts
and that it belongs to one of the 16
participants of karapika's class we
don't know the specific conditions under
which silent majority activates but we
do know that it needs to make itself
known to one person in the room although
that person is not the target of the
attack afterwards the true Target will
be afflicted with four conjured snakes
which together can drain a human body of
all blood in 11 seconds this attack does
appear to have a certain range although
that is unknown but the final condition
we do know is that if the attack is
stopped then silent majority's effects
will be bounced back to the user
basically meaning that they will die
instead if I was to speculate this is a
very powerful ability and I think the
condition of making itself known to a
person who who isn't the target is
probably employed to balance out the
speed in which it kills it's a condition
that actively gives the people around
the target a small window of opportunity
to prevent the attack and therefore kill
the ability user instead but funnily
enough the result of this is that we now
have a death game within our death game
there's The Wider raging succession war
and within that we now have a bonus
death game of silent majority we also
know that the purpose of silent majority
is to eliminate 10 targets so it's not
necessarily to put a stop to the nen
training but I guess if you kill most of
the students and then the training will
stop but either way it's going to keep
killing people one by one until krapika
figures out who the user is and how to
deal with them but here's the big thing
believe it or not becoming an unwilling
participant in two death games isn't the
end of karapika's problems because
unbeknownst to him the group who
murdered his entire Clan the Phantom
Troupe have also boarded the Blackwell
one with their own missions and goals
thus making krapika's life endlessly
complicated and nigh on hopeless for his
survival and we're going to explore the
impact of the troop in our next video